si on va par là on va devoir déboulonner
plus de 80% des personnages historiques
ça s'est il va falloir si on suit votre
raisonnement la france doit déboulonner
toutes les statues de jules césar qui a
massacré un million de gaulois et a
rendus esclaves
un autre million on va devoir demander
des comptes à l'italie si on va par là
charlemagne un des plus grand massacreur
de saxon si on va par là bien sûr plus
grave les purs et moi qui ai écrit et
aller les grands immigrés qui ont fait
la france hors jeu j'y tiens beaucoup
bien sûr qu'il faut représenter plus de
héros noirs dans nos statuts mais aussi
à des personnages qui nous restent
extrêmement ambigu le grand jaurès le
grand jean jaurès lui même a parlé du
rôle super delà des races supérieures
léon blum à le chantre du front
populaire a parlé de la supériorité des
blancs est le plus grand de tous victor
hugo est-ce qu'on va devoir alors que la
france je vous le rappelle a représenté
à de nombreux moments de l'histoire de
l'humanité l'espoir des hommes depuis
les bâtisseurs des cathédrales 1 l'art
français comme on le disait alors
l'humanisme de montaigne le siècle des
lumières qu'a produit sept demandes
d'émancipation de liberté d'égalité qui
a permis au peuple de se libérer du joug
colonial
ça c'est grâce à sa jules-ferry qu'a
voulu éduquer tous à l'école gratuite
public est obligatoire du grand jules
ferry ça donnait la possibilité de
construire une élite et tous ces peuples
ont pu se libérer de l'emprise française
on est en train de fracturer la société
française qui était beaucoup plus uni
comme disait kofi yamgname tous ces
noirs dont je vous parlais comptes qui
mérite une statue s'est vu finalement
félix éboué gaston monnerville qui était
le troisième personnage de l'état à de
design 1958 à 1969
il faut rappeler que la france ne s'est
pas des états unis ce n'est pas les
états unis et que malheureusement avec
votre vos actions vous allez provoquer
une fracture au bout le vivre ensemble
ne sera plus possible
retenez ce que je vous dis au lion va
vivre face à face et on va mourir
séparément
[Musique]